Joe Biden's green scheme is a total flop
but he is still forcing it on Americans
car companies are pulling back on the
production of electric vehicles and
there's a simple reason why nobody is
buying them a group of big automakers
including Ford Tesla and GM are slowing
down production because of lackluster
demand more than 3,000 car dealers
signing a letter opposing Biden's
electric vehicle mandate talking about
how the cars are quote stacking up on
our lots a new study is also revealing
the true cost of electric vehicles which
is roughly the equivalent of $17 a
gallon and here's another big blow to
Joe Biden's gas car ban the Democrat
Governor of Connecticut is now
withdrawing his State's electric vehicle
mandate this is what we got to do this
is how you bring down the price see if
we can satisfy some of the naysayers get
them on board just like they were until
recently and see if we can keep
Connecticut on a track that's going to
make a difference for us and our kids
but leave it to our stumbling president
to ignore all the signs of the coming EV
disaster Biden out in Colorado pushing
his green agenda building a clean energy
Future made in America it's part of the
progress we're making growing the
economy from the middle out and the
bottom up not the top down when I took
office we set a goal to produce 100%
carbon free electric by
2035 and because of my commitment to
clean energy Future made in America
clean energy companies started investing
here okay Dana Ford one company as an
example is projected to lose a whopping
$45 billion dollar from EVS this year up
from three billion last year even though
so this I don't understand why America
has to keep relearning the laws of the
free market so the Administration wanted
to medal they said here we go we're
going to give the the automakers this
kind of much money we're going to give
consumers this kind of a discount and
we're going to make the auto the the car
dealerships they're going to be the ones
that are going to get this across the
finish line and these guys are saying
it's not working we had a car dealer
from New Jersey on today saying I can't
move the cars he can't even get people
to take a test drive right and he's got
all this extra inventory that's just
sitting there and the White House tells
them to pound sand they're not trying to
do anything but do you think the car
dealers don't want to make money
of course they want to make money but he
says that people who live in apartments
think well where am I going to charge it
they get frustrated for example that the
trucks when you go to tow something or
put a trailer on the back it they don't
work as well and people are saying
they're still too expensive and they
don't want it anymore this is a house of
cards and when the thing when when the
House of Cards starts falling down in
States like Connecticut watch out the
bottom can fall out very quickly Jessica
why do you think Americans are so
resistant to the president green
agenda I think that what's going on with
electric vehicles is part of the green
agenda obviously but it's not the
entirety of it so I think this part of
theend yeah I'm going to address your
question directly and then I'm going to
add something uh just so we're okay I
think that Ned Lamont who by the way is
one of the more popular governors in the
country is very smart to do this and you
saw it also during the pandemic with
Jared polus who's the Democratic Govern
of Colorado where President Biden was
just being responsive to your
constituents and this even links back to
what we talking about with mayor Brandon
Johnson you just have to listen to your
people and you can you can change rules
for that you can say this is something
we want we aspire to right he said in
the clip that we showed I want to get us
there the goals are too aggressive we
can't move that quickly hopefully this
will engender more Goodwill towards e if
we take a break on this continue with
your gas cars Etc there's also this
problem that for the Fords of the world
and GMS people are buying Teslas if
they're buying electric vehicles they
haven't been able to get people on mass
to buy these other versions of it and
Tesla just has a different kind of Sheen
to it and people feel like the price can
be justified it's also driven by
wealthier people that are doing it so if
you're asking middle class people to do
it it's not resonating the same way
Biden's green agenda though has had a
lot of really big successes so he was at
this wind plant CS wind it's the world's
largest wind Tower manufacturer they
just broke ground on a $200 million
expansion direct result of the inflation
reduction act 850 new jobs that have
come now to this Tiny Town um 99% of the
clean energy investments in Colorado are
in counties with below average weekly
wages 68% in counties with higher than
average child poverty this is helping
people on the ground for real there's
been 7 billion overall investment in
manufacturing clean energy semi
conductors EVS batteries Etc that are
helping average Americans and and that
is part of this as well and why he
should be out there talking about
it Jesse the uh Biden Administration
just unveiled a massive set of Highway
emissions regulations As Americans are
getting ready to spend money for the
holiday and the finalized rule requires
state and local Transportation agencies
to establish greenhouse gas reduction T
targets that they may not be able to
make because people are not buying these
vehicles they're not hitting any of
their targets and half of the offshore
wind projects off the east coast have
been canceled or about to be cancelled I
was trying to find where the market is
to buy a green new car and I couldn't
figure it out because if you live in the
city where are you charging it if you
park on the street and if you happen to
be able to afford a garage it's like $
to $800 a month more they don't have
Chargers in garages and if were are you
going to buy another car that's electric
and you have two cars in a garage in
Manhattan that doesn't even happen all
right so then you're out in the
countryside are you actually going to
buy an electric car in the countryside
you have to drive miles and miles and
miles you won't be able to charge it and
then I'm thinking if you do happen to
charge it out in the countryside it
takes 20 to 40 minutes to charge who has
that kind of time to sit around to the
charging station I got errands to do and
I got to be back before dark and then
for safety reasons and then so now
you're only targeting the suburbs and so
who lives in the suburbs you have some
older people live in the suburbs older
people older people in the suburbs are
not buying electric cars it's just too
different they're not going to just
start they can barely do email and then
you have Suburban Housewives all right
and Suburban House Husbands usually the
women don't control which car to buy
sometimes it's a
collaboration sometimes it's a
collaboration no no
no F the women choose the cars you're
right yeah sure okay fine maybe anyway
let's just say the women that I know at
least aren't tech people they're not
like oh let's get an electric vehicle no
that's not what they're about so the men
in the suburbs a lot of them drive
pickup trucks if they don't drive a
truck they're conservative and they're
not buying an electric car so now you're
just having this Market here this is
liberal Suburban House Husbands those
are the only people in the market for an
electric car that's not a big Market
thank you Jesse all right as an older
suburbanite Greg yes do you have an
electric car not yet uh but a financial
tip I have bot stck and extension
cords you know um I have a theory that
they're trying to replace our fossil
fuel cars with EVS that would not be a
great no I think the government's
getting spanked by the Invisible Hand of
of the free market this is what happens
when you Embrace a goal that's not based
on a system but a desire or a wish if
you want you know like me washboard abs
and 7% body fat you need to create a
system for it you can't just wish that
you have 7% body fat and washboard abs
so they treat this massive overhaul in
your life like it's an electric car just
press forward and it'll happen no you
need a system to do do that I think
there's this is another area where uh
something like EVS were based on
projected climate models that turned out
to be false the estimates predictions
have been off by 20% whatnot they lied
to us they lied to us in order to ban
appliances to uh eliminate fossil fuels
to ban gas power to engines and to shame
us into eating insects and uh imagine if
they did it the right way because I
think that Jessica's right you know
there you introd ruce EVS that are cool
as an alternative uh and give it time to
become convenient this is what musk did
with the Tesla and his new truck is
magnificent but it's expensive but
wealthy people will buy the expensive
thing remember it was all the wealthy
people that were buying these giant VCRs
and the flat screens and getting
computers first and they were costing
thousands and thousands of dollars but
over time they became more efficient
faster better and cheaper that's what
Americans understand that like electric
cars become a alternative to what we
have and who knows over time they'll get
better but I think they drove this
argument into a bad place fear-mongering
and we have a Americans have a pretty
good BS detector on like you know what I
don't I don't need to do this because
the the Earth is is collapsing it's not
happening and and and and we're seeing
that these climate models are not
bearing out the world was supposed to
end in a couple of years it was supposed
to already end already be yeah and it
hasn't happened just tell us that this
is actually going to be a great way to
get around and maybe we'll listen that's
what mus did with the m with the Tesla
cars hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else